foreign
[Music]
Comic-Con that we have known that in the
coming years so many new films and
series of the Marvel Cinematic Universe
will be released today in order to give
you an overview of the more than a dozen
new releases here's our original episode
on phase five and six of the MCU we give
you a short and precise rundown of all
the projects so that you have an
excellent overview after watching this
video
Phase 5 kicks off on February 17th 2023
with Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania
director Peyton Reed is already
celebrating his third Ant-Man film with
Paul Rudd in the lead role in addition
to appearances by Evangeline Lilly as
hope Van Dyne and Michael Douglas is
Hank Pym fans are especially looking
forward to the appearance of the new
super villain King the Conqueror played
by Jonathan Majors King takes over from
Thanos who has not been featured since
Avengers end game and makes his second
appearance in the MCU after the Loki
series a first trailer is already
available but it has not yet been
released to the general public and was
only shown at Comic-Con from reports we
knew at least the quantum realm plays a
crucial role and with Modoc who is
embodied by Bill Murray another villain
makes his film debut we are still
eagerly awaiting the publication of the
trailer and are already looking forward
to the groundbreaking film which will
introduce Phase 5 of the MCU at the
beginning of next year
next up is secret Invasion this is a
Disney plus series that will be quite
special according to the official
website there is talk of a crossover
event series which seems like a first
for the MCU it will star Samuel L
Jackson as Nick Fury and Ben Mendelson
at scroll Talos this makes the cast
identical to Captain Marvel where the
scroll first made his appearance
basically it is about the shape-shifting
creatures that have been infiltrating
Earth undetected for quite some time
they can change their appearance as
often as they like and mimic people in
such a way that the other person does
not become suspicious of course this
also includes the well-known Marvel
heroes who will certainly be addressed
plenty of times throughout the series
this may also be what is meant by the
term crossover event Series so that we
are curious to see how those in charge
will realize the series the release date
of secret invasion is not known for sure
yet Disney is only given a time frame of
spring 2023 but we do hope for more
detailed information soon
a real highlight in Phase 5 is the third
and final Guardians of the Galaxy part
so far the movie is scheduled for May
5th 2023 and is expected to feature a
large cast of stars as usual the actors
some of whom have already appeared in
Thor love and thunder include Chris
Pratt as Star-Lord Zoe Saldana as Gamora
then diesel is Groot Bradley cooperis
rocket Dave Batista's Drax and Karen
Gillen as nebula also joining the cast
is Will Poulter who plays MCU newcomer
Adam Warlock the latter is also
connected to the new villain who's
expected to give the Guardians a hard
time we are talking about high
evolutionary who is extremely strong and
capable of manipulating energy and
matter among other things in Guardians
of the Galaxy 3 he is played by chukwudi
awuji and in theory opens many doors to
other characters who have not played any
role in The Guardian so far including
Scarlet Witch and Jessica Drew AKA
Spider Woman we are excited to see the
final outcome and look forward to James
Gunn's Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3
which unfortunately will be the last
guard against movie in the MCU for the
time being
next with Echo a Hawkeye spin-off series
will also be hitting Disney Plus in the
coming year as in Hawkeye Alaqua Cox
will play Maya Lopez AKA Echo and will
also get support from Charlie Cox as
Matt Murdock Alias Daredevil returning
to her hometown she's looking to make
peace with her past in addition she
explores her Origins as a Native
American and tries to prove herself as a
useful member of her community in terms
of style the series is supposed to be
similar to Moon Knight which means that
it will also contain some Supernatural
and mystical elements this does not
appeal to all fans since this is not the
case in the comics well at least we can
look forward to the appearance by
Charlie Cox and there is talk that
Jessica Jones will be featured in the
movie as well her presence could help
welcome Jones to the MCU and lay the
groundwork for more appearances in the
future there is no specific release date
yet but Disney did reveal summer 2023 as
an approximate time period for the
premiere of echo
also coming to Disney Plus in the summer
of 2023 is the second season of Loki
this will be the first MCU series to get
a second season needless to say we will
see Tom Hiddleston back here as Loki
however who else will join the cast once
again actually the entire cast is
planned to return as Hiddleston recently
revealed on Jimmy Kimmel Live thus we
can look forward to Google mabatha raw
as ravana Rensselaer Owen Wilson as
Mobius M Mobius Sophia dimartino as
silvi and one Mi masaku as Hunter B15
just to name a few in terms of content
we can initially expect some chaotic
conditions Sylvia started a Multiverse
War Loki is in another dimension and he
who remains has come to power so it is a
huge spectacle into which order must
first be brought how exactly the
characters will find their way back
together and whether they will even
recognize each other is something that
will only be revealed once we get to the
summer of 2023
next up in mid-summer is Captain Marvel
2 The Marvels the movie is set after the
events of Doctor Strange in the
Multiverse of Madness and there are also
already three main characters who are
sure to appear Brie Larson is Captain
Marvel Tiana Paris is Monica Rambo and
Iman villani is Kamala Khan should the
rumors prove to be true we will also see
Lashana Lynch as Monica's Mother Maria
Rambo who died of cancer after the snap
and would presumably appear in
flashbacks also talked about his
Valkyrie from the Thor movies who will
again be embodied by Tessa Thompson yet
it is still unclear how exactly her
character will fit into the plot about
which many questions remain to be
answered as well at the end of the first
film with Carol Danvers she set out to
find a home for the scroll threatened by
the cree Empire and what impact her
Mission had is not known still besides
we expect that Captain Marvel and Kamala
Khan will work together to explore not
only Earth but also other parts of the
universe no further details are
available yet but we do know that the
movie is scheduled to hit theaters on
July 28 2023
information concerning blade is still
scarce however we know that mahershala
Ali will play the lead role but little
else has happened since the announcement
at Comic-Con 2019. in addition to Ali
two other actors have joined the cast so
far namely Aaron Pierre and Delroy Lindo
even if not much else is known about the
reboot people are hoping for the
characters Abraham Whistler or Blade's
mentor jamalafari to be featured there
are also rumors about the involvement of
the boy star Anthony Starr who is
supposed to play the villain Dracula we
continue to await new information and
look forward to the theatrical release
of blade in early November 2023
also scheduled to Premiere in Fall 2023
is ironheart the six-part series was
officially announced in December 2020
and will introduce the eponymous super
heroine to the MCU in the starring role
we expect to see Dominique Thorne who
previously starred in Judas in the black
Messiah or if Beale Street could talk
for example and she is still more of a
newcomer to the Hollywood business now
she will succeed Robert Downey Jr in his
role as Iron Man and breathe new life
into the MCU rather than being a
billionaire inventor she is a student at
the famous MIT where she enjoys secretly
using the equipment for her own
experiments a first appearance is
already scheduled to be made in the
upcoming black panther wakanda forever
before the series is then released on
Disney Plus in the fall of 2023
things will then continue a bit gloomier
sometime in late 2023 or early 2024 as
we have known since this year's
Comic-Con Agatha coven of chaos will be
released around the turn of the Year
this will be a one division spin-off
that focuses on the centuries-old Agatha
Harkness in one division we have
previously seen the encounter between
Wanda and Agatha which ended with Wanda
becoming the Scarlet Witch plus Agatha
was the one who brought Wanda and the
dark hold together in the end however
Agatha was imprisoned by Wanda which is
possibly where the series picks up and
shows how Agatha escapes the clutches of
Wanda through a Sentry's old knowledge
in Arcane magic in regards to the cast
to date only Catherine Hahn has been
confirmed as Agatha with further
announcements still to come in any case
we will keep you up to date
in Spring 2024 a familiar character
returns to Disney and now also to the
MCU Daredevil after Charlie Cox embodied
the role of the blind lawyer at Netflix
from 2015 to 2018. it is now time to
further develop the Persona in the MCU
and what better way to do that than with
a series of his own in addition to Cox
as a Title Character we will also see
The Return of Vincent D'Onofrio as
Kingpin who already made his first MCU
appearance in the Hawkeye series at the
past Comic-Con there was sadly not a lot
of information other than the title in
an approximate release date fans appear
to be very excited about the series
nonetheless the only concern that it's
still bothering some Daredevil fans is
the way the series will be made many
hope that the series will be as adult in
the MCU as it was on Netflix where the
content was indeed less Motley and more
Dark and Bloody however we'll have to
remain patient at least until the first
trailer gets released which is
unfortunately not expected to happen
anytime soon
with Captain America new world order
another MCU film will be released on May
3rd 2024 with Anthony Mackey as Sam
Wilson we will also get to know a new
captain who officially replaces Chris
Evans in his role the script is
currently still being written by Malcolm
Spellman and Dylan Musson both of whom
have already worked on the Falcon and
the Winter Soldier apart from Anthony
Mackey as Sam Wilson an appearance of
Sebastian Stan as Bucky Barnes Alias
Winter Soldier is also being considered
after all he has already starred in
every other Captain America movie there
is also an indication of Julia Louis
Dreyfus as Valentina Allegra de Fontaine
as she was already seen in the
post-credits scene of Black Widow so an
appearance in Captain America New World
Order is not that unlikely in terms of
content not much is known yet although
there are a few questions that the
ending of Falcon and the Winter Soldier
did leave unanswered for example Joaquin
Torres might take on the role of Falcon
in the future while John Walker could
become the main antagonist of the fourth
Captain America movie Captain America
New World Order hits theaters on May 3rd
2024.
the final installment of Phase 5 will be
Thunderbolts alongside Captain America
4. this will be the mcu's second feature
film in 2024 and it will revolve around
the Thunderbolts these are somewhat like
The Suicide Squad of the Marvel universe
as they tend to be anti-heroes who
occasionally do good things and are
unpredictable in their actions and
through their different characters there
are multiple characters being considered
for the Thunderbolts including existing
MCU characters Baron Zemo Taskmaster
Abomination Elena Bulova us agent ghost
Winter Soldier and also Valentina
Allegra de Fontaine accordingly the
storyline is just as vague as the cast
about which there is no information yet
either way Thunderbolts concludes Phase
5 of the MCU and sets the stage for the
next three long-awaited films
with Fantastic Four the first movie from
phase six of the MCU will be released in
November 2024 after John Krasinski has
already appeared in Doctor Strange in
the Multiverse of Madness as Reed
Richards from Earth 838 we have somebody
who also be seen as Reed Richards from
Earth 616. if this is not the case other
possible candidates include Jamie Dornan
from 50 Shades of Gray It's Always Sunny
in Philadelphia actor Glenn Howerton and
Penn Badgley from you in the meantime it
was also reported that in addition to
Jamie Dornan as Reed Richards the team
would also include Amanda Seyfried as to
storm Joe curious Johnny Storm and even
Hollywood Legend Steven Spielberg as
director similar to the countless cast
rumors are the story possibilities first
and foremost with Namor Dr juman
Galactus it would be possible to
introduce as many as three villains into
the MCU and rely on dozens of comics as
a basis until more info is available
however we will just have to be patient
then in May 2025 after a weight of
almost six years we can finally look
forward to the next Avengers film the
title of the film is Avengers the King
Dynasty it will be directed by Destin
Daniel [ __ ] and bring the Multiverse
Saga to a climactic conclusion together
with the sequel Avengers Secret Wars the
main villain will be Kang who by then
has already been introduced in Ant-Man
and the WASP quantumania the question of
how the composition of the superheroes
will turn out until then and who will
ultimately be part of the Avengers after
the previous group broke apart after
Avengers end game is certainly exciting
feel free to let us know in the comments
what your Avengers Dreamcast looks like
the theatrical release of Avengers the
Kang Dynasty is scheduled for May 2nd
2025.
the story continues almost seamlessly
six months later in Avengers Secret Wars
there is much to suggest that we'll be
dealing with Dr Doom and the so-called
incursions in the sequel in the comics
The Secret Wars are a gigantic event in
which heroes and villains end up in
battle world and have to compete against
each other also nearly the entire
Multiverse falls apart and battle world
is eventually created from its parts
although the release of Avengers Secret
Wars is still more than three years away
we are already eagerly anticipating the
epic battles and the probable conclusion
of phase six which will happen starting
on November 8th 2025.
that was our new original episode on
Phase 5 and phase six of the MCU this
time even in a much bigger format feel
free to drop us your thoughts on phase
five and six in the comments and what
you hope to see in the upcoming movies
and series
[Music]